Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to play with a magical AI
where we just sit in our armchair, say the words,
and it draws an image for us. Almost anything
we can imagine. Almost. And before you ask,
yes, this includes drawing corgis too.
In the last few years, OpenAI set out to
train an AI named GPT-3 that could finish
your sentences. Then, they made Image-GPT,
this could even finish your images.
Yes, not kidding. It could identify that
the cat here likely holds a piece of paper
and finish the picture accordingly, and even
understood that if we have a droplet here
and we see just a portion of the ripples,
then this means a splash must be filled in.
And it gets better, then, they invented an
AI they call Dall-E. This one is insanity:
we just tell the AI what
image we would like to see,
and it will draw it. Look. It can
create a custom storefront for us,
understands the concept of low-polygon rendering,
isometric views, clay objects, and more.
And that’s not all. It could even invent
clocks with new shapes when asked.
The crazy thing here is that it understands
geometry, shapes, even materials. For instance,
look at this white clock here on the blue table.
And it did not only put it on the table, but it
also made sure to generate appropriate glossy
reflections that matches the color of the clock.
And get this, Dall-E was published
just about a year ago, and OpenAI
already has a followup paper that they call
GLIDE. And believe it or not, this can do more,
and it can do it better. Well, I will
believe it when I see it, so, let’s go!
Now, hold on to your papers, and, let’s start with
a hedgehog using a calculator. Wow, that looks
incredible. It’s not just a hedgehog
plus a calculator. It really is using
the calculator. Now, paint a fox in the style
of the starry night painting. I love the style,
and even the framing of the picture is quite good,
there is some space left to make sure that we see
that starry night. Great decision making. Now, a
corgi with a red bowtie and a purple party hat.
Excellent. And a pixel art corgi with a pizza.
These are really good, but they are nothing
compared to what is to come. Because it can
also perform conditional inpainting with text.
Yes, I am not kidding. Have a look at this little
girl hugging a dog. But, there is a problem
with this. Do you know what the problem is?
Of course, the problem is that this is not a
corgi. Now it is. That is another great result.
And if we wish that some zebras were added here,
that’s possible too, and we can also add a vase
here. Hmm…look at that. It even understood
that this is a glass table and added its own
reflection. Now, I am a light transport researcher
by trade, and this makes me very, very happy.
However, it is also true that it seems to have
changed the material properties of the table,
it is now much more diffuse than it was before.
Perhaps this is the AI’s understanding of a new
object blocking reflections. It’s not perfect
by any means, but it is a solid step forward.
We can also give this gentleman a white
hat. And as I look through these results,
I find it absolutely amazing how
well the hat blends into the scene.
That is very challenging. Why? Well, in light
transport research, we need to simulate the path
of millions and millions of light rays
to make sure that indirect illumination
appears in a scene, for instance, look here.
This is from one of our previous paper that
showcases how fluids of different colors paint
their diffuse surroundings to their own color.
I find it absolutely beautiful. Let’s
switch the fluid to a different one, and,
you see the difference. The link to this work
is available in the description below. And,
you see, simulating these effects
is very costly, and very difficult.
But this is how proper light transport
simulations need to be done. And this GLIDE AI
can put in new objects into a scene and make
them blend in so well, this to me, seems also a
proper understanding of light transport. I can
hardly believe what is going on here. Bravo.
But wait, how do we know if this is really better
than Dall-E? Are we supposed to just believe it?
No, not at all! Fortunately, comparing the results
against Dall-E is very easy, look. We just add
the same prompts, and see that there is no
contest. The new GLIDE technique creates sharper,
higher-resolution images with more details, and
it even follows our instructions better. The
paper also showcases a user study where human
evaluators also favored the new technique.
Now, of course, we are not done here, not
even this technique is perfect. Look. We can
request a cat with 8 legs, and…wait a minute. It
tried some multiplication trick, but we are not
falling for it. A+ for effort, little AI, but, of
course, this is clearly one of the failure cases.
And once once again, this is an AI where
a vast body of knowledge lies within,
but it only emerges if we can bring it out with
properly written prompts. It almost feels like a
new kind of programming that is open to everyone,
even people without any programming or technical
knowledge. If a computer is a bicycle for the
mind, then OpenAI’s Glide is a fighter jet.
Absolutely incredible. Soon, this might
democratize creating illustrations, paintings,
and maybe even help inventing new things.
And here comes the best part - you can try
it too. The notebook for it is available in
the video description. Make sure to leave
your experiment results in the comments,
or just tweet them at me. I’d love to see what you
ingenious Fellow Scholars bring out of this AI.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!